you want to talk about depravity i
it's valentine's day so i was hoping we
could talk about sort of higher
romantic
notions of love
mature
deep
rightly ordered notions of
love but we've got to talk about
joe biden's
new energy official who is in charge of
nuclear waste in america
you you want to talk a bit people aren't
talking about and i feel like we should
all be talking about the leather daddy
dog fetishist that joe biden just put in
charge of america's nuclear waste
the man's i don't even want to say his
name
i because i don't want to embarrass him
personally except i guess i wouldn't be
embarrassing him personally you know i i
wouldn't want to reveal someone's
personal sins
needlessly that's not something i want
to do but in this case it's not a
personal sin it's a very public very
creepy scandal for someone who is not in
any way shy about this kind of behavior
who is now in a fairly powerful position
in the u.s government so i guess i'll
say his name his name is sam brinton
he is the new deputy assistant secretary
of spent fuel and waste disposition at
the office of nuclear energy at the does
this is a pretty serious position and
and sam brinton identifies as a and this
is in his own public biography as a
non-binary
man who is who engages in something
called puppy play
where which i i guess is sexual i guess
it's sexual but i don't
it's a sexual in a very strange
he
has men who pretend to be dogs and he
pretends to be their owner
and then for much of the this
activity they're not
it's all sexual but it's not like
explicitly sexual until
until it is it's really weird i've we've
sometimes talked about this people write
into this show a lot and say you know i
look at porn and i don't want to look at
porn but i'm really addicted to this
stuff and and one of the things that
happens
is that you you know you look at it's
just like naked ladies on the internet
and by the end you know you're looking
at um you know two chickens doing
calculus and somehow that's sexual but
you don't really know how that's sexual
but it but it is it's still part so
that's that's basically what this guy is
into
and he brags about this he gives classes
on this sort of thing on all various uh
fetishes and kinks and strange behaviors
he gave an interview to the student
newspaper at the rpi rensselaer
polytechnic institute where uh
brenton this is according to the
newspaper quote throughout the entire
talk brenton was open about his
experiences the kinks he partakes in and
the nature of his relationships he left
us with countless anecdotes like how he
enjoys tying up his significant other
like a table and eating his dinner on
him while he watches star trek
me i like brunettes
you know that's kind of one of and and
this guy likes to tie up his sexual
partners like they're a table and eat
sushi off of them while he watches
science fiction
in in the old days this guy would have
been a huge blackmail risk because he
has all these weird sexual behaviors
that he's indulging all the time and
people would find out about it and then
they could blackmail him
now he's not real he's not really a
blackmail risk because it's all public
so there's nothing to blackmail
but that is really
really degraded
it's really no one
no if this man were your father i don't
think that or you're your grandfather i
don't think somebody would say you know
you know my grandfather i so admire him
he fought in world war ii that's right
and my grandfather he worked at the coal
mines and it was tough work but he
earned a living for our family and he
put his sons through school and and then
here i am today his grandson they say oh
wow michael that's really interesting
yeah my grandfather liked to dress up in
leather and whip other
extremely perverted men who dressed up
like doggies and feed them a bowl of
water yes our you know our grandfathers
aren't we so proud of them
grandfathers right aren't there people
to look up to no you would be extremely
embarrassed and ashamed of this because
it's very shameful behavior
it's not in any way dignified
and
previous i'm not even saying i'm not
even saying that this guy is so bad
because he's got some disordered sexual
desires it's a fallen world lots and
lots of people have disordered sexual
desires i'm not but
in a normal healthy society the right
the thing that you would do is repress
those desires
because they are shameful
to to quote nor macdonald one of the
great
ethicists and moral philosophers of our
age sex is a filthy shameful thing that
is obviously only meant for procreation
okay and this is when you when you just
spend your time
indulging in fantasies
and
childish
delusions
that's that's not a distinguished life
okay that's not something to write home
about
there was there was a poet a sort of
modern poet who said the thing about sin
even beyond how bad it is and you know
it harms people and harms yourself is
just such a waste of time
but that's what we're living in today
we're living in an age where adults
fully grown adults will spend hours and
hours and days and days and weeks and
weeks
dressing up in costumes and playing
pretend and doing all sorts of weird
creepy sex stuff that is childish
behavior for a childish society that
would appear to be past its prime i'm
glad you liked that clip now
please ring that bell subscribe
you can get the notifications here when
our new videos come out and if you don't
you can head on over to apple podcast
spotify stitcher google play wherever
you get your audio podcasts
subscribe to the michael knowles show
podcast leave a five star review we will
see you next time
[Music]
you